[Music]
last week the website Gawker you hear
about this declared bankruptcy after
losing a 140 million dollar lawsuit to
Hulk Hogan okay yeah they lost the suit
there's Hulk Hogan looking all serious
in court
brother Hogan sued Gawker for posting a
private sex tape without his consent so
now with bankruptcy looming there's a
lot of stories that Gawker was working
on but unfortunately these stories may
never see the light of day no yeah
however and this may not be legal I did
not check with lawyers I got my hands on
some of the stories that Gawker was just
about to publish Wow yeah and again I
want to stress I did not consult any
attorney right it's cheaper that way
yeah yeah those guys cost more because
all they do is say you can't do yeah I'm
on the clock that's a bad idea
right you're gonna get sued well guess
what I think I should show them to
people right now wouldn't you like to
see
these stories these are stories caucus
was just about to publish and they're
gonna go to waste otherwise so let's
check them out here's the first Gawker
story that was almost published look at
this check it out blurry video of Alec
Baldwin eating a banana is this anything
oh that's just great
yeah look at this one does Fox News
Chris Wallace have dick pics he's not
telling us about oh this one
guess which TBS talk-show hosts yells
Palpatine during sex
[Laughter]
probably Samantha bee yeah at least
Samantha yeah yeah okay look didn't look
like her profile should have read
through these beforehand oh well check
this one out
why Coolio still matters and does he
have dick pics he's not telling us about
exclusive audio of Pedro is having a
difficult time knocking went out of the
park in an RVs restroom stall
what we're not gonna find out about
we're not gonna find out no finally JLo
and J law compared J labias in jail a
Vittori they're gone forever those
stories bad
you